Greetings today we want to welcome Brianna Moo,
who is the Co founder and the head of development,
that giant space gap,
the game studio nearby and is also on a couple of podcasts that relay FM
isometric,
which is about the game industry and rocket,
which I think is about a sorted geekery copics so welcome Briana.
Okay.
Oh,
thank you so much for coming today.
All right.
Why wouldn't that Google for having me today and you know,
coasts,
I know you were responsible for getting me here,
so I definitely,
definitely appreciate that.
My name is Brianna Wu.
I'm head of development it giant space count.
Okay.
I'm an expert in the unreal engine and um,
you know,
when I got into this field,
like most software engineers,
I did this because I love engineering.
You know,
I love programming,
I love all this geeky stuff.
You know,
I was a child.
I remember my parents were so hesitant to get me a computer because they knew
that the moment they did,
I would just stay in my room nonstop and never leave the house.
You know?
So we're find myself,
you know,
especially in this last year,
um,
we have kind of being an unintentional figure for women in tech.
You know,
I just want like,
no,
this isn't why I gotten to this field in the first place
he owned.
That leads to our first slide.
Like,
why do we have to talk about this?
You know,
what I've discovered along the way is that we really don't have a choice.
Women in this field to talk about gender issues.
These things are we're going to be talking about today.
They really make or break the careers of women in this field.
You know,
often you have,
sometimes I sit there and I listened to my male colleagues in the field and
watch what they tweet or what they talk about.
And it really amazes me just how little thought they have to kind of apply to
some of these social things that a lot of women engineers have to talk about and
think about every single day.
Little things like being talked over in meetings,
not being recommended for promotions.
And you know,
Google itself has done a lot of really wonderful work on unconscious bias.
So,
you know,
what I want you to know is I would rather be up here talking about anything else
today.
Unreal engine,
you know,
implementing unreal Android,
open GL just about anything.
But the only way it's going to get better for me and the other women that work
in this field is by talking openly about that.
So this is can be a presentation today.
You know,
I'm not,
Oprah Winfrey was software engineer and this is going to be,
I'm going to lay it out on the table for you in the same way I would a software
bug.
So,
you know,
when I made this talk a few years ago,
um,
I was on my way down to WWDC and I kind of threw it together.
Um,
you know,
on a whim and you,
what really struck me at the time is these issues of gender and tech had really
come to a head,
you know,
this was early in 2014,
my friend,
uh,
Julian Horvath,
um,
received a lot of gender based harassment,
harassment,
it get hub.
I'm sure you read about that.
There was a founder there was um,
you know,
accused and some really horrific ways of uh,
you're beating up his girlfriend 150,
two times on tape.
Um,
you,
you had things like code Babes coming out and you know,
Google,
which I think speaks to your credit now,
have released your,
um,
numbers of diversity in the workforce.
I think it's really worth noting that when that story came out in 2014,
I and a lot of people were like,
this isn't so good.
But with you being open with that number,
you started to see a trend of other companies like apple bringing that number
out.
And it's not any better.
So,
you know,
I think that speaks to your credit,
and for me,
you know,
every single time I give this talk,
it's more and more frustrating to me because,
you know,
there are these incidents that break out about what women in tech are facing
than make the news in every single time.
It just gets longer and longer and longer.
You know,
it got to the point where I couldn't even update these slides because it would
just keep going through it for 10 minutes.
So we're just going to go through it super quickly right here,
you know,
and for me,
one of the most bizarre experiences of my life is,
you know,
I prepared this talk before Gamergate happened to me.
You know,
um,
I don't know if you're aware of what's happened to me in this year.
Um,
you know,
I'm up 265 death threats in the last 11 months in this field.
I have to talk to the FBI and prosecutors,
you know,
this week about updates in my case and trying to get some of these things
prosecuted.
So,
you know,
what I've kind of unintentionally found is by speaking out on these issues,
um,
it's literally put my life in danger,
you know?
So I hope that kind of communicates to you how strongly I feel about being up
here talking about this today.
So what we're going to do is we're going to go through nine things very quickly
and you know,
there's going to kind of be a negative and there's going to be a positive.
So what we're going to be talking about is some unconscious things that men in
this field kind of tend to do.
And before we get into this,
I just really want to make this clear.
Google has done some amazing work on unconscious bias and it's really important
to note these problems if you do them.
Do not make you a bad person.
I myself have some of this same unconscious bias myself sometimes.
Um,
our member,
I was an apple two years ago.
I was sitting there and a man was trying to sell me a computer and a woman was
trying to sell me a computer and I found myself unconsciously realizing I was
talking more to the man about my computer needs.
And I'm a woman in tech figure.
We all have problems with these kinds of unconscious biases.
So I just want you to know this is not personal.
This is just talking about a problem in an objective way.
So the first thing I'd like to talk about is you need to stop treating sexism.
Like it's just another controversy to discuss.
Um,
there is an inevitable pattern that happens.
two days ago I wrote a piece for polygon praising,
uh,
Kajima his team for making women a playable character in metal gear,
solid five.
Again,
this kind of quite a bit of sexist controversy.
Um,
yeah,
this is a piece I didn't think you'd be controversial because I was actually
praising and aspect of the game for,
again,
they've got a lot of feminist criticism.
And what I found happened was,
although my response was a lot more positive than usual,
um,
I was inundated with men talking to me,
emailing me,
writing me dynamite into my house,
you know,
doing whatever kind of point to discuss it with me.
Um,
and this is a really common theme when we're talking about sexism in the
workplace.
This is not like talking about the ending of last or a TV show.
This is not like trying to talk about is it a blue dress or a gold dress?
You know,
these are deeply,
deeply personal issues for all of us.
And you,
what ends up happening is sometimes when you tried to talk about your lived
experiences in this field,
you'll have male engineers and we'll come up to you and they start talking about
it.
Like it's a problem of implementing a framework,
right?
Like they are completely objective and just trying to think through it.
And what I think they don't realize in that moment is it's a real unconscious
problem because what you are doing is kind of saying,
prove to me that you're right.
And there's an unconscious message there that my lived experiences are not,
you know,
your your opinions on this Trump,
my own lived experiences.
This is not a very helpful way to do it.
What you're unconsciously doing is when I say,
look,
I've had x problem of sexism with x,
Y,
and Z,
and you're like,
yeah,
I'll prove it to me.
Yeah,
well,
have you thought about this?
Oh,
well,
it's just x,
Y,
or z.
You were dismissing my life and the difficult things that I've gone through.
What we need you to do is to start showing basic instead.
I want to give you an example.
I had a really good lifelong friend of mine that went through a divorce a few
years ago.
You know,
I knew his wife,
I knew his child,
and he now,
when my friend was sitting there talking to me about his divorce,
you know,
I didn't sit there and say,
hey,
but did you really try to make her happy?
Would you really present there?
You know,
I know you feel like she's being unreasonable on this,
but I'm sure it was just blah,
like that would be unbelievably obnoxious,
right?
But that is what happens every single time that women start talking about our
experiences in tech.
And again,
this is not intentional,
but what men in this field ended up doing his tone,
this,
their own interpretation of our own lives is incorrect in the known understand
when we talk about this stuff is very difficult for us,
is emotionally risky.
We're trusting you.
That leads us into this,
you know,
this is something that happened back in 2014.
Um,
you know,
I'm a limit in my thirties.
Okay?
If I'm telling you a king cat called down the street,
like trust me,
that's something that's really happening.
You know,
I don't,
you know,
I'm an engineer.
So yeah,
I'm talking about being out at San Francisco at WWDC and gang harassed
constantly on the street.
So I tweet about this and I ended up getting literally hundreds of responses to
this telling me that my interpretation of my own life is wrong.
This happens all the time in technology.
Again,
this is very hurtful.
So what we need you to do instead is just stop doing that.
Again,
this is every single day of our lives.
You know,
there's some things that you have to live to experience and let me give you an
example.
We talked a lot this year about police violence towards people of color,
particularly black people.
I have the privilege of being white in our society.
When I get pulled over by the cops,
I don't have to stress that you know that the cops are going to be violent.
To me,
a lot of people in this room today have that same privilege.
You know,
I can't speak to any number of experiences in life and that is true for all of
us.
So when someone is black and they are telling you about their experiences with
law enforcement,
you need to just listen to it and understand that that lived experience trumps
your own hypotheses about the situation.
If someone gay is telling you about coming out to their parents or the
discrimination they faced as a child,
you need to listen to them.
If someone is transgender and they are telling you about the difficulties in
transitioning,
you need to listen to them.
And even if the opinion were hypothetically incorrect,
the emotion that that person is feeling is absolutely true.
I want to tell a very quick story about this.
Um,
related to this point.
So a few years ago,
um,
they were doing a study on Alzheimer's patients who have this phenomenon of when
you put them in assisted living care facilities,
they wake up,
they're terrified,
they're confused,
they're scared,
they think they should be home and they're not.
They're in a strange hospital.
So what they would end up doing is constantly leaving this hospital and going
down to the bus stop where they would be weighted on for hours.
And what this study found out is that the people in the hospital would go down,
it,
start yelling at these poor,
you know,
elderly people that were suffering from the disease.
What do you need to understand is in that situation,
even if that patients,
if the facts of the situation,
we're not,
that they were in a place they weren't supposed to be,
their terror was absolutely real.
Their frustration was absolutely real.
So when these hospital employees were coming down and yelling at them,
they didn't realize that their emotions in that situation,
we're very true.
So what do you need to do again is start just simply respecting those lived
experiences.
These are our lives,
these are our stories.
When you respect our lived experience,
you end up respecting us as individuals.
Oh,
this really makes me frustrated.
So there is a phenomenon.
And um,
when you talk about women in tech issues that it's,
I'm sorry,
I swear it is like you're in court and all of a sudden like you end up getting
it flipped and you end up talking about,
um,
you ended up talking about how these issues affect men.
It is amazing to me just how instantly the script flips and I find the subject
talking to,
if I'm talking about the things I face,
the subject instantly comes to if it's fair to men.
Let me give you an example.
Yesterday,
um,
apple at a rather large event that we're talking about.
Um,
you know,
the iPad pro new apple TV and I was live tweeting a few thoughts about it.
I couldn't help but no for the first 30 minutes of it,
but there were barely any women on stage.
So I tweet something to the effect of,
well,
here,
you know,
here are all apples,
white guys who are all Microsoft's white guys and now we've got Adobe swipe guys
coming on stage,
the imed Luge with tweets from people saying,
well,
you can't have quotas for women.
You can't do this.
How dare you insinuate that men shouldn't be on stage,
which is a really,
really,
really unhelpful response.
I want to talk a little bit about where that comes from.
We may have heard the word privilege a little bit lately in the truth is men in
this field are kind of blind to how great you've got it.
I don't think you understand what it's like to go to an engineering event and be
the only person that looks like you there.
I don't think you understand what it's like to go to a recruiting event and have
people talk to your husband,
assuming he's the engineer.
We can't even update the software on his iPhone.
You know this,
this entire system has been built for you,
for your comfort.
So when we start talking about other people's comfort,
you're so used to it working for you that just the slightest bit of upset.
There's a lot of defensiveness that really happens very quickly with that and
it's not helpful.
Again,
this is not about you and I promise you every single woman engineer in this room
has heard these opinions a hundred times before,
like a tape on repeat with all respect.
You know,
I have heard the argument against quotas for women in tech hundreds of times
this week.
You know,
there is a really,
really beautiful thing called the bring theory that I'd like to talk about.
So you know,
the idea is how not to say the wrong thing to someone.
So the idea is you are right here in the center of the circle when something
goes wrong for you.
So imagine if you have cancer or you've just lost your spouse or you're going
through a divorce or your parents have died.
If something really,
or you've gotten 165 death threats in the hair,
you know,
imagine you are here in the center of the circle.
This is not a good place to be.
So what the psychologist figured out is when you were in the center of the
circle,
she had cancer,
she had a colleague come to her while she was in the hospital recovering from
cancer surgery.
Who said to her,
well,
you know,
you need to realize this cancer isn't all about you.
It's affecting people in our department.
And she thought a lot about that conversation and why that was so obnoxious.
So there's this thing called the ring theory.
So at the center of the circle,
which again is not a good place to be,
is the aggrieved in the outer limits of the circle might be like close family
members,
loved ones,
your spouse on the outer circle might be colleagues and on the,
the thing here might be strangers.
So the idea is comfort flows in grievance flows out.
So if you're not in the center of the circle or in one of these inner rings,
inevitably kind of making it about you is unfortunately obnoxious.
What you need to do is very simple.
Just listen instead.
Okay.
This is a really big one.
Um,
I want to talk very openly and honestly about this.
You know,
I'm 38 year old engineer.
I don't have any children.
You know,
my,
my husband and I made the choice to really hyper focus on our careers.
I have been blind to this for a long time and I was very blind to this until I
had women with children come work for me.
Or you know,
people on my staff get pregnant.
In the game industry where I work,
we talk a lot about things like death threats,
rape threats,
um,
you know,
sexual harassment,
women getting hit on a conventions.
Something we are AV almost silent about is the way we treat women with children
in tech.
And yeah,
this doesn't personally affect me by what to tell you straight up in my career,
I've seen more women leave over this issue than anything else.
He knows someone in the society has to have the children.
It's not like women made choice of help this.
Right.
And what I think people don't understand is how ridiculously expensive childcare
is here in Massachusetts.
Do you know that having daycare for your child,
it's as expensive as tuition at umass.
I want you really think about that every single year your child is in daycare.
That costs tuition and fees.
Absolutely.
It's,
it's unconscionable.
You know,
this is a really big deal.
So what ends up happening with women have,
you know,
children in tech is they end up slowly suddenly being shown the door in.
I've seen this again,
I have unconscious biases too.
And what I found at first when my employee with the child,
you know,
she got pregnant,
my cofounder and I found myself wrestling with all these unconscious biases.
Is Amanda going to be present at our workplace?
Is she going to be able to get her job done?
Is she going to start talking about her kids nonstop?
Which was absolutely wrong for me to think I have.
You know,
I've thought about that and I've grown from that.
This is an unconscious bias a lot of people have.
What you need to know in this is for parents of all genders,
not just women.
Part of respecting a parrot in the workforce means respecting their children.
That means if a parent needs to leave at five to go pick their child up,
respecting that person means respecting that their family comes first.
This is really,
really important.
This is a really hard one and I've run into this a lot in,
I can't tell you how many networking events I've been to in a bar at night with
a bunch of dudes in their 20s drinking right here in Boston was one of them.
Went to a while back.
Those right across the street.
What has happened in the field of computer science and engineering is this is a
field that was built from the ground up to be by men for men and less stress.
This is unconscious bias.
But what ends up happening is she,
you,
you'll have a culture of networking that is built to serve men in the way that
you like to network,
like going to a bar and having beer.
Let's take that example for a minute cause I'd like for you to think about it.
So let's say you were an engineer at Google in your 20s,
and you choose to go have a,
um,
you know,
like a,
a meeting out with the guys on your team at the bar next door after you leave.
Let's think about how that's affecting women.
So if you're a woman in say your twenties I think you may not know,
that doesn't feel emotionally very frequently,
like a safe place for you,
like a lot of you guys drinking heavily and you're the lone woman there.
I can think of three specific friends that have been sexually harassed in the
situation to the point that they've been forced to leave their company.
An HR hasn't helped them.
It's not the best situation.
If you're a woman in your thirties maybe you have children.
How many Moms d know that really want to go hit a bar at eight o'clock at night
when their kids have to go to school the next day?
This is one of these situations where the system has been built to work for a
very certain kind of person and it very unintentionally excludes a lot of people
and let's be honest,
networking is how you make careers.
It makes or breaks it.
This is really important.
So what we need people to do,
what I need everyone in this room to do is to think about widening your network.
If Google has a networking meeting or recruitment meeting to bring in engineers,
maybe don't have a bar at night,
maybe have a luncheon here at one o'clock like we're having right now.
Maybe do it earlier.
You know,
it's not enough to just simply believe that women need to be included.
I'm a software engineer.
If I go write some code for my game and it doesn't run,
the problem is with my code.
I don't sit there and go,
well I just don't know why it's working,
but we'll just keep compiling it.
And that will be that.
The method that we use to recruit engineers in our field is not working.
I've heard from so many people when they tell me,
well,
we put a job posting online and no women applied.
And that's just the end of that.
You know,
we have made so many advancements in the last 1520 years and yet we can't look
at the hiring process and realize it overlooks a lot of candidates.
Let me tell you a story.
Business Story of how the lead engineer at my team came to work at my company.
So this is a woman that was fresh out of college and you know,
she had knocked on the straight and narrow,
you know,
she didn't get a cs degree and then just instantly get into the workforce.
She had some life adventures along the way,
so she had been working for us part time and we were just dazzled by her work.
She was doing technical rigging in three D,
which is very,
very difficult process.
We'd loved her work and we kept encouraging her to apply to the lead engineer
position and she didn't do it.
I asked her to keep coming in and sit with me as we were interviewing other
candidates for this position.
As we did that,
she realized that she had the exact same qualifications as the men we were
interviewing for that position and that gave her the confidence to move forward.
So yeah,
just for whatever reason,
and it's really too much to get into here,
a lot of women are kind of trained by society to not believe in ourselves and we
don't always apply for these kinds of positions.
So what you need to do is to widen your networking efforts to make sure you're
looking at absolutely everyone we face a lot more nourishing to getting your
foot in the door.
Okay.
Um,
you know,
this is hard
so many times when you try to talk to people in tech about even a very small
behavioral thing they might've done that is not helpful.
It gets defensive very,
very,
very quickly.
And I think part of this problem is,
you know,
being like self,
identifying yourself as a racist or sexist or a homophobe is nearly impossible
because we get all these messages from society that these things are bad,
they're terrible.
So what ends up happening is you tell yourself,
hey,
I'm not a bad person.
I'm a nice guy.
I care about women.
You know,
you think of like this extreme example and you say,
I'm not that.
And you self identify yourself as a nice person and you're unable to hear any of
the criticism there.
And I want to be straight up with you.
I think we could do a better job with this as a society of giving people a
break.
I think we have a really unfortunate tendency to when someone makes one mistake
often unconscious,
often unintentional,
of kind of crucifying them about it.
To be honest,
I make mistakes all the time in my field.
I've told you about some today.
I don't think that makes me a bad person.
You know,
we have got to get past this,
we can hear about these behavior problems and move forward.
I think it's really,
really telling.
In all the years I've been speaking about women in tech issues,
I have almost never had a guy come up to me afterwards and say,
Hey Briana,
you know what?
I am part of the problem.
There's almost never happened.
It's always those other guys.
It's always the other examples.
The truth is if you think that the problem is someone else,
you are a part of the prop.
We've talked a lot this year about like people of color and you get,
again to give an example where I have failed,
you know,
my staff for Alaska and that we shipped revolution 60 happened to be all white
people.
And I looked at that and I realize that I was not bringing people of color into
my own company to evaluate people of color for these positions.
And I realized I had a responsibility to change myself,
change my networking habits,
and make sure it was bringing people of color in for those positions.
So this is a mindset where I'm not saying,
Hey,
I'm not a racist.
I have nothing to fix here.
Hey,
I have no part to play in making it better.
This is a very helpful attitude that all of us needed to have.
And again,
this is all about responsibility.
It's thinking critically about your behavior.
What I'd love about one of the videos I've seen from Google and unconscious bias
is,
you know,
what they found is the science shows.
If you take one of the things I'm talking about today,
if you just take one thing,
if you say,
Hey,
I'm not networking enough of women,
I am invalidating people's experiences,
few make a commitment to just change one thing today.
The science shows that that is going to cause you to start thinking about more
things and it will make you a better person and a better teammate.
We all make mistakes.
Okay.
So you know there is a misconception I feel in tech that the problem women face
is like don draper sitting in and uh,
check office somewhere is drinking some scotch and talking about how broads
can't code,
right?
That's the hypothetical situation that we think discrimination is in this field.
Like I have never had from a professional.
Someone tell me to go back to the kitchen,
right?
Like these kinds of moments are not the real problem.
So what we've kind of set up is this idea in our minds that the real problem is
like some raging sexist stereotype from the 50s the science shows that's not
quite right.
Sexism in tech according to the science of it is death by a thousand cuts.
And what happens is it's like every single day you are in this field.
If you're someone that's a person of color.
So when this gaze someone that's a woman,
you know,
you find yourself slowly dying this death of a thousand cuts.
And how that happens is it's little things all day long,
like people not inviting you to meetings,
people you know,
underestimating your capacity as an engineer.
People assuming that you don't know your field even when you may have dedicated
your entire career.
Pour it.
I had an example yesterday while I was talking about the apple TV event.
I want to tell you straight up,
I wanted the,
I know more about running the unreal engine on um,
you know,
on apple platforms,
apple mobile platforms than almost anyone else.
You could probably find 20,
30 people may be in the world to understand this subject as much as I do.
And I was talking critically about some of the engineering choices the apple
made when developing this platform in particular,
the 200 megabyte limit,
which is kind of obviated by a cloud solution.
I was inundated by hundreds and hundreds of people writing me,
assuming they knew more than they than I did in this field and telling me I was
wrong when all they had was a rather obvious fact that was mentioned in some,
some tech documents.
This is a really good example of a death of a thousand cuts like this is just
one minor thing that happens,
but it happens over and over and Dover,
Dover and Dover,
they're called microaggressions and they kind of slowly push you out at field.
Another good example at Apple's event yesterday,
um,
they happen to Photoshop a picture of a woman into smiling using the new iPad
pro,
right?
This is a pretty tone deaf moment,
Like you guys don't understand how often when you're walking down the street,
you're instructed to smile.
You're told you it'd be prettier if you would just smile.
This happens all the time.
It's when apple had not had any women on stage yet at that point and they're
photoshopping a woman smiling.
It's a really tone deaf moment.
That's something that a lot of guys I saw on Twitter just didn't understand
that.
It was just a little thing that was really just kind of obnoxious.
It pushes us away.
Yeah.
This is a really good example.
This happened last year.
Know this is just a slide at a conference and you know,
it's completely tone deaf.
Stuff like that will happen to you almost every single day if you're a woman in
this field.
What we need you to understand is real sexism in this field.
It's very,
very subtle.
A good example of this,
a happened here in Boston is harmonics.
You might read this week that they got 15 million new dollars in venture capital
funding.
So you know,
a friend of mine that worked at harmonics was telling me this story.
So she was sending out on a meeting and there were looking at getting a new um,
person to come in for an engineering position and the team leader kept using
masculine pronouns when asking someone to come in from the job,
well,
this engineer,
he should have x years of experience with x,
Y,
and z.
He should be x.
He should live in x.
He should have this kind of background.
And she stopped him in the meeting,
said,
excuse me,
you know,
this could be a man or a woman that we hire for this position.
This engineer proceeded to then completely talk over her,
belittle her objection,
and said,
this is not a problem.
He means every body.
That's just a very small thing that happens.
It's subtle.
This is a really hard thing to understand and this is something,
again,
I've had learned this in my lifetime.
The absence of privilege is not oppression.
And I say this with all respect to all the male engineers in this room.
This is a system that really,
really works for you.
So when we're talking about changing the system just a little bit so other
people can come in and you have awesome people on your team,
you know,
we are talking about changing things and I want to be clear it is going to
disrupt some of the boys club atmosphere.
They exists and tech that is not oppression.
That is a quality.
I want to give you a very quick story.
So I was over at MIT the other day and I was um,
giving presentations
afterwards.
Um,
I had some people that were really moved by it and they were telling me stories
about being out with drinks with the guys afterwards and there was this one
engineer,
those on the team and who was sitting there and just having drinks out with
this,
his buddies.
And he was really,
really angry about the talk that I gave and he was talking about how he felt
like he had never fit in anywhere in his whole life.
Something I have a lot of empathy for,
I can understand that.
So I felt the entire same way growing up.
So what he was saying was he was really,
really scared.
The TAC was going to change to this place where he couldn't like how bro time,
you know,
it couldn't have pictures of bikini girls always screensaver and it would be
like a different kind of atmosphere.
As much as my heart goes out to that person.
Cause I think we all need,
we all need to want to belong to a social group.
It's not fair for him to prioritize his own comfort over just equality for gay
people,
for women,
for people of Color.
The culture tech has been built in your own image.
I was a pac stuff,
um,
two weeks ago and I found myself,
there was this weirdest moment that I had,
um,
you know,
it was a 23 old kid,
as a white guy,
a sitting there talking to me and he was talking about how I was terrified he
was never going to find an engineering position.
And the whole time I was sitting there talking to him and I was realizing all
the assumptions I had in my mind.
He looked like an engineer.
Like you got kind of messy hair and you know,
just wearing a tee shirt,
a professional event.
He kind of looked like that stereotype and in the back of my mind I'm going of
course it's going to find a job and I found myself saying I don't know anything
about its technical expertise.
I don't know anything about his education.
I don't know anything about how well he plays with others,
but it looks like the part,
right?
It's just another example of the entire tech industry being built in your image
and when you close your eyes and think about someone working in this field,
it probably doesn't look like me or other women,
you know?
And the truth is I get so much hate mail in speaking out against this and this
is what,
this is before Gamergate that I got this,
this is just absolutely terrible at stuff like this.
I get every single day speaking out about about this.
This is something that would be a benefit to everyone here to understand.
Let's be straight up.
Tech is going to change.
The momentum is on the side of women and people of color.
And other minorities.
We are talking about these problems more and more and more and I feel very
confident the tech in 10 years is going to look different than it does today.
I grew up in Mississippi,
which is a state that was described by them.
Okay.
A sweltering with the heat of injustice and oppression growing up I sure did
meet a lot of people that were extremely homophobic or racist and you know,
even in my own social groups in college,
I would find these people and what would inevitably happen,
especially with gay rights,
is we kind of have this person there that was kind of ranting about,
you know,
gay being able to get married and then slowly be pushed out of our social
circle.
Do you know what I mean?
Like they just had views or kind of dated and we started moving away from them
in the same way on talking about this and utterly pragmatic terms,
this change is happening.
Your workforce will include more women in the future.
So it's not just that this is the right thing to do.
This is to your own career advantage to develop these skills,
to learn to work with other people?
You know,
one of the best skills for any tech professional is being able to work well with
the team.
A lot of times when I talk about women in tech issues,
there's this assumption that women,
that attack is just a chick thing,
right?
Like,
oh well,
you know,
that's just a a woman problem and I don't really have to deal with that.
I was at a tech event last night,
those VIP event with investors and wouldn't startup founders.
As much as I love events like that,
it sometimes feels like there's a,
um,
it feels like there's a trade off in this field where,
you know,
kind of the powers that be will let you know,
women go have our lunches over here and they'll pay for us to have an auditorium
and do some networking events.
But nothing really changes.
I'm going to tell you,
in all honesty,
straight up sexism in tech is not a problem with women's behavior.
I could say that one more time.
Sexism in tech is not a problem with women's behavior.
This is a male behavior problem.
I can be up here and I can speak to you about changing this,
but the only person that can make this better is she you.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to start a conversation right now.
I will answer any question the entire world.
So who's going to be brave enough to put their hand up first?
We will.
We will do that.
Hi.
Thanks for having the courage to come here and give this talk.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Um,
your slides are refreshingly direct.
Didn't expect him to be that.
Uh,
that's so,
because I found that people don't,
don't seem to respond to them that well,
but in your experience,
um,
you know,
if you're with a bunch of people,
one of them makes a,
a comment that they don't understand,
no problem,
you know,
inappropriate.
Do you,
have you found it's better to actually be more direct with them and Saint
[inaudible] then just say straight up that's wrong.
Instead of saying,
well,
maybe you could,
maybe it's not quite like that.
Yeah,
I,
that's a wonderful question.
Um,
let me answer an equally directly.
If you're a woman and you do that and had that direct conversation,
you'll get tremendous blowback,
which is why so many of the women I know one game down are very,
very careful about dancing around this issue and like just hinting to it as
subtly as she can because she gets so much blow back.
This is where you personally can do the most good in the entire world.
So yeah,
with the Gamergate thing,
we do have men on our field that are speaking out like Chris clue.
Um,
it's one of them.
Arthur Chu would be another,
they don't get a fraction of the death threats that I get remade it.
Gunther Zoe Quinn gets from Randy Harper gets,
so what happens is when you have that male privilege,
you were able to kind of pull your body aside and be like,
Hey,
can we,
can we just talk about that?
That's not really cool what you just said and just have an open conversation
with them about that.
That is almost no risk for you.
So,
um,
I think if you're a woman,
you need to realize that we're going to be blow back for that.
I personally made the choice to just answer directly.
I'm not Oprah Winfrey again.
Um,
this is where I would really ask guys to step up and help us out.
You can do so much good.
You,
you have no idea.
So let's go to another question.
I suspect most,
most of the people here in the room are,
uh,
are,
are probably on your side,
are probably very receptive to this message.
Thank you.
Um,
and yeah,
I am too.
And thank you for coming to get the talk.
Huh.
Um,
do you think it's better to try to engage people who aren't here,
uh,
and maybe wouldn't be as receptive or do you think it's better for them to come
to this conversation of their own volition?
Sure.
I think that's a really good question.
Um,
is there anyone else here see the piece on box last week?
Those talking about what Nernst don't understand about politics by Dr box.
And did you see that that was a 10 out of town talk.
So I called up that writer on the phone afterwards and I started asking him that
exact question,
how we could get that answer.
So let me tell you about the science suffix and they'll Google nerds love
science.
So he has a lot of expertise in climate change denial.
So you know people that don't want to believe in global warming.
So what happens is with some people you are correct is impossible to change
their minds.
There's nothing that you can say there's ever going to make them feel
differently on that you cannot scientifically change someone's opinion,
what you can change scientifically someone's behavior.
So the human mind has this really interesting trait that,
um,
we'd like to think of ourselves as rational creatures,
but we're not with the psychological trick where we decide how we want to feel
and then our minds act like lawyers and justify the thing that we want to
believe.
And you know,
like if you're a programmer and you've learned to short circuit that to a
certain extent,
like we tend to be very logical creatures,
but you know,
that is the overall human tendency there.
So,
so you can't turn someone's opinion.
You can change their behavior.
So what happens if you make a social cost to that person doing something?
If every single time they speak up,
they face consequences for that.
Even if it's just someone going,
hey,
that's not really cool.
Hey that made me feel uncomfortable.
Hey that's me didn't really key.
It's like about this.
Why?
Maybe what happens over time is you change that behavior and then the
psychological trick where you decide how you want to feel and then the mind
justifies it.
You just side that you want to feel like not doing this because the social cost
is less and then your attitudes slowly start to change.
So with the climate change denial thing,
this would be,
um,
if you can get through any way possible to like get tax rebates,
to get people to put solar panels on their roof,
to save on energy efficiency.
What they found when you do that is their opinions change.
So you can have the most,
um,
dedicated climate change denier.
But once I get that,
you know,
government tax rebate,
so like put solar panels on their roof,
suddenly they're proponent of renewable energy.
It's exactly the same way in the field.
So scientifically those the best weapon that we have.
Do we have another question?
So first of all,
thank you for the choice you're making.
I can not imagine choosing to live a life or death threats were just sort of a
background factor.
It's really down.
Um,
I think it's necessary to have conversation with speak for,
there would be people like you.
So I'm grateful for you for doing something.
I don't think I'd be up to do it.
So,
um,
I,
the question I was curious about asking is do you have some understanding your
intuition about where the depth of vitriol comes from?
Sure.
I mean,
some of it I buy as being the,
the confusion between absence of privilege and oppression and I get,
you know,
I get that,
but it doesn't feel like enough to me.
And there's something about it that I'm just not wrapping my brain around.
Oh,
I've,
I've spent an entire year about this question.
You know,
this is,
this is very insightful.
So this is as best as I can figure it out.
Cause that's a really,
that's getting at the core of the problem,
which I love.
So,
um,
how many people here are gamers?
Can you raise your hand if you're a Gamer?
Great.
So the biggest mistake my parents ever made was getting me an intent,
no entertainment system in 1985 I remember opening that box at Christmas and I
remember my grades went to Hell.
You got to stop socializing and stopped doing my chores.
And that is all I did.
That's still doing it.
Oh,
so,
but what are,
remember about that era,
and this was 30 years ago,
like Maria turns 30 sin guys,
this is amazing.
Um,
what are,
remember about this era was how marketed the product was for boys.
And this shows up in all these subtle ways.
Do you know their voice void been to core Mario Games where you could play as a
girl character princess peach?
The first one is Super Moria too in 1988 and then as far as the core Mari at
titles,
we had to wait 25 years for Princess Peach to be playable again and this kind of
making this a boy space.
It was very deliberately chosen by the Nintendo marketing team back in 1985 they
said that they were targeting boys between five and 10 then when the Super
Nintendo came out in 1982 they just rewrote the same documents and we're
targeting boys five to 15 so what has happened is I think we'd like to say that
the problem is a bunch of misogynistic 15 year olds and that is part of the
problem.
Good.
I think if you want to look at it more deeply,
there are all these unconscious messages that been telling boys now,
35 year old men,
right?
The games are their space.
It's not women's space.
It happens in all these subtle ways,
right?
Princess Peach is always waiting to be rescued in the council when women are in
games,
you know,
we're frequently oversexualized,
right?
We're always the sidekick or the damsel in distress and we have huge giant boons
and lots of cleavage out.
And what it is is a thousand unconscious signals that had been sent to men
saying,
this is for you.
This is not for women.
And they,
they have this intellectual short cub would,
they might be theoretically fine with women playing games,
but the instant we bring their lived experience into it and say,
well,
you know,
it really hurts me to never be able to be the,
the playable character in the game.
Well,
you know,
I'd like to see a woman larger than size six represented in a video game.
You know,
all these,
how many games can you think of where you've seen a mom as a playable character
id now,
how many,
what percentage of women are going to have kids in their lifetime?
So it's like,
it's all unconscious by the people in our field,
but they feel it's,
it's kind of the same as politics.
Like certain people feel their identities being taken away and they get very
defensive.
Did you have a follow up?
I do,
but I,
yeah,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Just what I'm,
if I take what you're saying and I take it just sort of trying to
wrap my brain around it.
What I'm hearing is that there is,
you know,
people create or adopt or dive into spaces that are restricted to one set of
people when they are threatened.
Correct.
Or the set of people.
Okay.
So I'm hearing you as a,
as saying that the people who are feeling,
I mean,
you could look at what they say online and it's pretty clear to yeah,
but look,
they're much winter mentioned something.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
Yeah.
The state saying that there is a class of men that feel threatened by the
presence of women in gaming seems a little obvious.
Um,
but it does bring up the next question,
which is sort of why,
what's going on.
They are that those people feel like they need that space to feel safe.
Let me,
let me tell you another quick story.
I grew up in Mississippi.
Um,
so my senator at the time,
Trump live,
um,
I actually worked for him one summer,
so I'll leave that there.
Don't judge me.
I was very young.
So my Senator Trent Lott once did a study for the Republican Party in the south.
And I'm keeping this very apolitical.
We're just talking about facts here.
Okay.
So,
um,
he did a study,
looking at what would drive voter behavior to vote for the Republicans that
year.
So the tested all these questions like the Democrats will raise taxes,
blah,
blah.
They found this one question that raised through the roof,
the response of it.
And the question was,
the Democrats want to take away your culture and white southern males just
responded off the charts to this like just ridiculously high.
So what happens is there's a really deep set evolutionary part of our brain
where we're programmed,
like from back when we were living in caves to have ingroups and outgroups and
we're just programmed to say we're in this group.
And then this group over here is the other and they are a threat.
And you can see that portrayed all through history for war through all of this
stuff.
So what's happening is it's really tapping into this very reptilian,
primordial part of the brain where people feel like this is their ingroup,
their identity is based in it and they're scared as can be taken away.
So see,
I just wanted to pass on a question from a speaker last month,
Elizabeth Schawinski who just wanted to know what we might see next from you and
also how friends can help with anything you're working on.
Oh,
that's a really great question.
I love her.
You should check out her book.
Um,
so what I'm working on next is as if dealing with Gamergate,
we're not big enough for me.
Um,
we're working on the venture capital scene right now.
Let's do a multimillion dollar expansion.
Um,
and I can't talk about some of it,
but,
um,
we're very interested in what we're calling emotional gameplay dynamics.
So to me,
I feel like we have reinvented this wheel for 30 years in the video game
industry.
How many first person shooters to be played?
Because let's be honest,
call of duty is not that different than doom.
It's like we keep reinventing the same idea because it's the same people there.
What we're doing is taking a step back from the entire video game industry,
from all the assumptions that we've made and we're saying what is the goal in
the video game industry?
And to me the goal is the Holodeck.
The goal is the hollow deck and to go and interact with different kinds of
people in emotional ways and learn things about yourself along the way.
So as we really have an explosion in VR technology,
we have some very interesting ideas of a frameworks to develop for this.
So we're raising millions of dollars for that.
Um,
as far as how to help me guys,
if I personally dealt with all of my death threats myself,
I would not do anything else with.
My time is just too much of it and it's sad,
but I'm just being straight with you being up here today.
People see this video on Google,
I will get threats,
I will get attacked and I have to employ at my company,
fulltime person to deal with my harassment,
to talk to prosecutors,
to talk to the FBI,
to document this stuff.
Cause I could not work in this field if I did.
So I've a patrion where people can help pay for that position because start ups,
don't have room for extra positions to pay people to file death threat and
charges with prosecutors.
So that's how you can help.
Um,
maybe we'll give a link to that in the video.
Thanks for that question.
Stepping back to the,
uh,
stepping back to the attitudes that lead to the,
it's just a horrible illness.
It makes me wonder where the cultural watchdogs,
right.
All along that these games were corrupting us during our formative years.
I tell you the weirdest story about that.
So I remember,
um,
who else here was a Gamer in the 90s with Jack Thompson.
Like,
do you remember that?
When they were worried about mortal Kombat,
um,
corrupting the youth.
And I remember being a teenager and being like,
oh,
that's so stupid.
That's so dog that's so full of crap.
And I'm not saying that it's not,
but what I'm tell you I experience that I had,
so they're coming out with hatred,
which is this game that's a mass murder simulator and you have a certain person
on steam that is demanding the creators ad modifiable tools.
So people can put me in that game to kill.
And Zoe Quinn and Anita Sarkeesian hint.
So I have gamers that want to do that.
And I keep thinking back to being a teacher and my strong opinion about violence
doesn't matter and look and just be straight up.
I know I'm going to answer.
They're like,
I think we should be able to make whatever games that we want.
And I'm certainly not pro censorship,
but I think something's really wrong in her industry and I think we need to
think about that.
So yeah.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah,
I,
I mean,
yeah,
I'm not gonna tell you mean you need to like start censoring games.
I don't,
I think it's impossible in an age of digital distribution.
But what I do believe is that Nintendo,
Sony,
Microsoft,
and steam have a responsibility to think about the product that they're putting
out.
When steam reversed their decision and did decide to release hatred,
which guys,
this is made by neo Nazis.
It's a white power thing to just go kill people and you'll watch the trailer and
there's a woman begging onto her knees for her life and you'll like stick a
shotgun in her mouth and kill her.
It is horrific and I don't think you should censor that by the government.
And I think in an age of digital distribution,
anyone can play that game if they want.
So,
you know,
the quick,
let's do,
can we do two questions super quickly?
Great.
Um,
you mentioned a couple of microaggressions.
You mentioned mansplaining and I'm interrupting.
I wonder if there's any others you want to call out?
Just maybe anything that's specific to the software development environment.
I think that,
I think a really big one would be assuming women do not know their stuff.
That's a really,
really big one.
It,
it hurts a lot.
I think talking over women in meetings,
and let me say this,
I love gender neutral examples.
Look,
a lot of it's here are software engineers.
Almost all the engineers I know are introverts,
right?
Like I'm not,
but the vast majority are.
What I have noticed and running my company is if I don't take a firm hand,
the extroverts end up talking over everyone in.
Introverts can't get a word in edgewise.
This includes a lot of women.
So if you are a product manager,
you have a strong responsibility as a team leader to shut down the extroverts
like me from monopolizing the entire conversation and letting everyone be hurt.
I could go into a whole bunch of them.
But I think that's a good example.
Last question.
Oh,
um,
so I was wondering,
I mean,
so there was a time right in the late tube in early transistor days when it
computing computer operators were mostly women because she has likes which board
operation.
It was basically seen as secretarial.
Um,
and my question was,
can,
are there any lessons we can draw from kind of the path of computing?
Is there was a time when it was indeed mostly women.
It wasn't prestigious position and became a prestigious position.
Ben came in there.
Anything we can learn from the early part of that history.
Yeah,
that's a historical pattern.
Believe it or not,
there's a huge pattern through history of fields coming along and being born.
Um,
you know,
and it starts off as very prestigious and women are drawn to it and there's this
pattern over and over again that men kind of move into from the field and ended
up changing it.
So,
um,
you know,
I would love to tell you what happened in competing in those early days is like
an aberration,
but it's not.
Um,
there is so much baggage that women face to working as professional engineers.
I see this with some of my friends' children who are,
you know,
14,
15 right now and they're put into a culture where beauty culture starts telling
them who their friends are,
what they look like is so much more important than doing that work.
We all know is so important.
Sitting in your bedroom and learning how to code,
you know?
So there are a thousand messages like that that we really have to move past as
this society.
Yeah.
Guy To leave it there today.
So thank you all for having me.
[inaudible].